welcome back to las vegas now working
from home has resulted
in easy access to food pantries and a
few extra pounds for a lot of people in
fact a recent survey showed 51 percent
of americans
want to lose weight well here's a way to
do it hello my name is john
i came to fast fit because i'm trying to
lose weight
and i tried everything i'm under the sun
weight pills
i've been on diets i've been gyms and
nothing worked i see fast food
advertised on tv
and i figured well i'll give it a shot
this is my last resort
and i came here and it was simply
amazing
uh just come in here you just relax and
you just lose the weight
congratulations to him for losing the
weight joining us this afternoon
is doug stuko stucco with fast fit
uh doug weight loss is a very personal
and emotional subject right to a lot of
people
absolutely you know people are very
private and very self-conscious
and you know the hardest thing is to
walk through a door
and ask for help but no need to worry
because when people come into fast fit
they're going to be they're going to
meet be met by some very very friendly
staff
very highly trained that really care
about the results
and they're going to treat them they're
going to think they're an old friend
because it is it's tough for people to
take that first step
there may be an embarrassment factor
there may just be
a fear factor whatever it is it is nice
to know that someone's there
that's empathetic to what they're going
through absolutely so what we're going
to do is we're going to have you sit
down with an expert
that's going to first of all learn about
you and what your goals are what your
needs are
and then they're going to educate you on
what we do
and we're going to do a general health
assessment
a comprehensive body analysis
and then you know show you what our
patent-pending fat loss process really
is and teach you about the technology
and help you get started so tell us a
little bit about the technology
what does it feel like what does someone
go through when they
go to you well it's actually very
relaxing
so you come to fast fit you know we work
on
a lot of things for health it's if you
want to look your best on the outside
you have to look your best on the inside
so when you come to fast fit our process
and to make a long story very
short it fires up the fat burning system
helps fire up the beta receptors on the
fat cells so we can
burn that emulsified fatty acid
and it works very efficiently and we're
seeing some success stories
on our screen here is this in
conjunction with
uh healthy eating and exercise do you do
you
support that or advocate for that well
absolutely you want to eat healthy
and we do give some advice on that
but the most important thing when that
fat now is released from the fat cells
we need to do some sort of a
at least a walk right we don't need any
strenuous activities but i need
some sort of movement and you will
metabolize
fat basically like you were when you
were 25 again it's pretty cool
ah for me that was just a few years ago
so that's good
right little throwback what are some of
the success stories you've seen and what
what are the results emotionally that
you see when people go through this
you know it's very emotional because
people don't even really believe it'll
work they just they're desperate and
they want something to work but nothing
else has ever worked there's not never
been a diet or exercise
program that really worked for them
especially people over 35
and people really are shocked when they
do see success first of all they're
going to get some
more energy and then they're going to
see some pounds of fat leave the body
and that's
great motivation for fantastic results
yeah and you're right when you're
feeling better about yourself it just
it changes the overall um demeanor uh
emotional outlook on life sometimes
absolutely it makes life fun again yeah
doug kuzzo
and i even worked on that beforehand and
i managed to mess it up in the intro but
doug cuzzo thank you so much for joining
us today
thanks for having me all right if you
want more information visit
fastfitbodysculpting.com
or call 1-800 fastfit the first 20
callers
are going to receive a special offer
fast fit has locations in summerlin
west sahara centennial and henderson